last video I talked about the dot
product showing both the standard
introduction to the topic as well as a
deeper view of how it relates to linear
transformations I'd like to do the same
thing for cross products which also have
a standard introduction along with a
deeper understanding in the light of
linear transformations but this time I'm
dividing it into two separate videos
here I'll try to hit the main points
that students are usually shown about
the cross product and in the next video
I'll be showing a view which is less
commonly taught but really satisfying
when you learn it will start in two
dimensions if you have two vectors V and
W think about the parallelogram that
they span out what I mean by that is
that if you take a copy of V and move
its tail to the tip of W and you take a
copy of W and move its tail to the tip
of V the four vectors now on the screen
enclose a certain parallelogram the
cross product of V and W written with
the X shaped multiplication symbol is
the area of this parallelogram
well almost we also need to consider
orientation basically if V is on the
right of W then V cross W is positive
and equal to the area of the
parallelogram but if V is on the left of
W then the cross product is negative
namely the negative area of that
parallelogram notice this means that
order matters if you swapped V and W
instead taking W cross V the cross
product would become the negative of
whatever it was before the way I always
remember the ordering here is that when
you take the cross product of the two
basis vectors in order I hat cross J hat
the result should be positive in fact
the order of your basis vectors is what
defines orientation so since I hat is on
the right of J hat
I remember that V cross W has to be
positive whenever V is on the right of W
so for example with the vector shown
here I'll just tell you that the area of
that parallelogram is 7 and since V is
on the left of W the cross product
should be negative so V cross W is
negative 7
but of course you want to be able to
compute this without someone telling you
the area this is where the determinant
comes in so if you didn't see chapter 5
of this series where I talk about the
determinant now would be a really good
time to go take a look even if you did
see it but it was awhile ago I'd
recommend taking another look just to
make sure those ideas are fresh in your
mind
for the 2d cross product V cross W what
you do is you write the coordinates of V
as the first column of a matrix and you
take the coordinates of W and make them
the second column then you just compute
the determinant
this is because a matrix whose columns
represent V and W corresponds with a
linear transformation that moves the
basis vectors I hat and J hat to V and W
the determinant is all about measuring
how areas change due to a transformation
and the prototypical area that we look
at is the unit square resting on I hat
and J hat after the transformation that
square gets turned into the
parallelogram that we care about so the
determinant which generally measures the
factor by which areas are changed gives
the area of this parallelogram since it
evolved from a square that started with
area 1 what's more if V is on the left
of W it means that orientation was
flipped during that transformation which
is what it means for the determinant to
be negative
as an example let's say V has
coordinates negative 3 1 and W has
coordinates 2 1 the determinant of the
matrix with those coordinates as columns
is negative 3 times 1 minus 2 times 1
which is negative five so evidently the
area of the parallelogram they define is
five and since V is on the left of W it
should make sense that this value is
negative as with any new operation you
learn
I'd recommend playing around with this
notion a bit in your head just to get
kind of an intuitive feel for what the
cross product is all about for example
you might notice that when two vectors
are perpendicular or at least close to
being perpendicular the cross product is
larger than it would be if they were
pointing in very similar directions
because the area of that parallelogram
is larger when the sides are closer to
being perpendicular
something else you might notice is that
if you were to scale up one of those
vectors
perhaps multiplying V by 3 then the area
of that parallelogram is also scaled up
by a factor of 3 so what this means for
the operation is that 3 V cross W will
be exactly 3 times the value of V cross
W now even though all of this is a
perfectly fine mathematical operation
what I just described is technically not
the cross product the true cross product
is something that combines two different
3d vectors to get a new 3d vector just
as before we're still going to consider
the parallelogram defined by the two
vectors that were crossing together and
the area of this parallelogram is still
going to play a big role to be concrete
let's say that the area is 2.5 for the
vectors shown here but as I said the
cross product is not a number it's a
vector this new vectors length will be
the area of that parallelogram which in
this case is 2.5 and the direction of
that new vector is going to be
perpendicular to the parallelogram but
which way right I mean there are two
possible vectors with length 2.5 that
are perpendicular to a given plane this
is where the right hand rule comes in
point the forefinger of your right hand
in the direction of V then stick out
your middle finger in the direction of W
then when you point up your thumb that's
the direction of the cross product
for example let's say that V was a
vector with length two pointing straight
up in the Z direction and W is a vector
with length two pointing in the pure Y
direction the parallelogram that they
define in this simple example is
actually a square since they're
perpendicular and have the same length
and the area of that square is four so
their cross product should be a vector
with length four using the right hand
rule their cross product should point in
the negative x-direction
so the cross product of these two
vectors is negative four times I hat
for more general computations there is a
formula that you could memorize if you
wanted but it's common and easier to
instead remember a certain process
involving the 3d determinant now this
process looks truly strange at first you
write down a 3d matrix where the second
and third columns contain the
coordinates of V and W but for that
first column you write the basis vectors
I hat J hat and K hat then you compute
the determinant of this matrix the
silliness is probably clear here what on
earth does it mean to put in a vector as
the entry of a matrix
students are often told that this is
just a notational trick when you carry
out the computations as if I hat J hat
and K hat were numbers then you get some
linear combination of those basis
vectors
and the vector defined by that linear
combination students are told to just
believe is the unique vector
perpendicular to V and W whose magnitude
is the area of the appropriate
parallelogram and whose Direction obeys
the right-hand rule
and sure in some sense this is just a
notational trick but there is a reason
for doing in it's not just a coincidence
that the determinant is once again
important and putting the basis vectors
in those slots is not just a random
thing to do to understand where all of
this comes from it helps to use the idea
of duality that I introduced in the last
video this concept is a little bit heavy
though so I'm putting it in a separate
follow-on video for any of you who are
curious to learn more arguably it falls
outside the essence of linear algebra
the important part here is to know what
that cross product vector geometrically
represents so if you want to skip that
next video feel free but for those of
you who are willing to go a bit deeper
and who are curious about the connection
between this computation and the
underlying geometry the ideas that I'll
talk about in the next video are just a
really elegant piece of math
[Music]
you